it's always good to chat with this man
he sits in this chair frequently when uh
when i have uh another assignment uh
great job whenever he sits in this chair
and he will be in a chair in a rose bowl
calling hawaii at
ucla one of five big fbs football
contests in the collegiate football
world coming up on saturday nebraska
illinois yukon fresno state utep new
mexico state southern utah san jose
state espn will be televising it and
this man will be calling it on westwood
1 radio our buddy ryan leaf here in the
rich housing show how are you ryan
i'm good rich how you all doing better
for talking to you
so um let's let's just jump into it real
uh before we get into the college
football
um
fully um i'll be honest with you ryan uh
as you know i root for you i root for
you all the time there was one day in
particular you in the rose bowl as a
matter of fact where i was not rooting
for you at all
no you heard was
[Laughter]
what's it like for you to step in the
rose bowl to walk into that beautiful
stadium that you played
in
with washington so excited so excited uh
what an iconic venue and to be back you
know uh being away from calling games a
year ago for this to be the first one
step into that into the terry donahue
press box who recently passed who i have
a really
really neat relationship with because he
recruited me and i watched him and
developed you know young men into
great men and and so it's it's just it's
really great uh and i want to say this
this this opportunity really presented
itself because of of your show and and
the fact that i got the opportunity to
sit in your chair and work with westwood
one that's that's really kind of it was
one of the best referrals i could get so
i i appreciate that of course uh but i
mean what memories will will be coming
back to you of course ryan it's this
it's all good what memories come back to
you when you when you're when you're
going to be walking in that stadium
yeah
just uh
just to come you know walking into that
stadium and seeing washington state
written in the end zone and i remember
looking over at two of my coaches who
got you know guys that i i'd known since
i got there as a freshman who had kind
of grown up as well into their coaching
their coaching prowess and they were
looking up at this uh at the sky and i
just i asked what are you guys looking
at is like we've made it and i go what
do you mean you've made it because we're
coaching in a game where there's a blimp
and uh that that made a lot of sense to
me i'm like wow yeah there's a blimp and
we're here and
we're playing for the national
championship of sorts against the
heisman trophy winner on those iconic
michigan wolverine helmets over there
uh and a little guy named tom brady on
the sideline who wouldn't even sniff the
field uh that game uh it was special day
special day as as many people can attest
to a controversial ending and and one
that i can always say that we didn't
lose that game we just ran out of time
oh okay i'll give you more of the floor
on that ryan what are you talking about
i don't understand what you're talking
about what do you mean
all right so on the final play of the
game uh there was two seconds left we
were on the 26 yard line going in uh i
chose to spike the ball
uh instead of running a play and as i
spiked it i looked up and there was
still a second left on the clock and
then it and then it kicked away the
officials would run off the field
michigan would kind of storm the field
but we were left at the 26 yard line
with the very controversial ending in
fact they would change the rule because
of that you are not allowed to spike the
football now unless you have three
seconds
on the clock so there's a there's a bit
of controversy to it i i i wasn't very
pleased with the official as i went
after him when the when the clock
finally went to zero luckily coach price
grabbed me and told me just to be quiet
and allowed him to then eviscerate the
officials on the right
good use of the word eviscerate so you
know just got to play better than the
rest ref though ryan although you had it
i know that wasn't there was that i mean
i was nervous as a cat i was so
nervous i remember the ending of course
and i remember you know the whole dream
season of charles woodson winning the
heisman and
and being out there on the rose bowl had
to complete it and i you know and i just
remember
all of that and i i just was wondering
what what the that thought process in
your head was just looking back now
where you are exciting
exciting and i and the fact that i get
to be in that stadium to do what i love
to do now
i think there's going to be a
just i'm going to be overwhelmed with
gratitude as i always am um but this
more more importantly because of of the
venue and
uh of of the opportunity which has
presented itself over the last year and
a half with everything that's gone on
you know we're us in the leaf house
holder pretty uh
pretty darn grateful and excited uh for
this college football season to kick off
macgyver's old enough now i think he
might be able to i'm able to to come on
a few of these trips with me and i'm
really really excited to show him some
of these big stadiums and and venues
that that college football played in
love it and where dad played the rose
bowl uh again on westwood one radio ryan
leaf call in the action who are you
calling the game with ryan uh paul
brewmeister uh really
easy guy dude he is just uh so two
quarterbacks in the booth yeah yeah two
covers are excited we're excited to get
get together with one another he gets in
tonight
uh he's such good people man but you and
burmeister would be a great listen on
westwood one radio and then um so chip
kelly um in ucla is this is this time
now like is this the time who does he
have the horses to compete in
in the pac-12 this year walk me through
that process first
right he does he has the horses he's in
year four he's he's got a extremely
senior laden team now everybody's
bringing back starters because kovid
allowed for everybody to pretty much
bring back starters right they have a
ton of starters coming back though their
veteran guys right they have
a tight end that can make make a big
difference the old line is
is is been around and has a ton of
experience they have great wide
receivers the only underclassmen
starters cam brown the transfer from
texas a m is going to really make an
impact but it all comes down to
uh dtr uh their quarterback fourth year
in ship kelly system
ups and downs been some great games some
poor games
uh and last year they were a team that
was on the cusp they played a shortened
season they lost four games okay by a
combined 15 points and
people are expecting them to make a
significant jump to go from a team that
has only won three or four games
a season in the first three years to
winning eight nine
uh possibly ten
this season that is a huge jump and i
always walk parking back to my sophomore
year where our team went five and six we
lost two games in overtime we lost the
rest by
points here or there and no one expected
us to do very well and we came out and
won five more games in the year before
went 10 and two went to the rose will
play for the national championship as we
just talked about this team's capable of
doing that the schedule is extremely
difficult extremely difficult they have
lsu coming into town next week at the
rose bowl for a huge game
but this was a first start hawaii is a
non-conference opponent if you can
believe this chip kelly has yet to beat
a non-conference opponent so this is
huge for them to get off to a good start
ryan leaf here on the rich eisen showed
breaking down ucla and hawaii one of the
you know big games
to kick off the college football season
he's calling it on westwood one where
many of you are also listening to this
rich eisen show on a rich ozone show
terrestrial radio affiliate so
um top five your top five going into the
season is
who
clemson clemson one oklahoma two alabama
three georgia for texas a m five that's
what i have
right now i think it's going to be
drastically different in terms of what
the sec turns out i think this is the
year texas a m makes a move and alabama
has to find their identity behind a new
quarterback in a whole new coaching
system so i didn't go quite shocked this
year in terms of of what the sec is
going to do i i went a little
differently um but uh expect a lot of
the same at the top of the list who
follows in the next five after that
we'll see if some teams can make the
jump in in infiltrate their north
carolina university of washington maybe
utah but we'll see but uh um those are
the five i have at the top right now
before the season starts your spencer
rattler guy ryan leaf
i am i'm a i'm a spencer rattler guy
like the young man out of out of arizona
i think lincoln riley has continued to
every single year put together fine
football programs they playing the big
twelve i don't think there's a team
besides iowa state that can really give
a much trouble this year therefore i
think their team that could go
undefeated get themselves back into the
college football playoffs and finally
maybe get over that hump and win a
semifinal to play for a national
championship we'll see we were talking
uh on the show yesterday uh nicole
auerbach of the
uh athletic their college football
writer um just saying how amazing it
would be for iowa state
to assert itself
right and and somehow some way
with spencer rattler in oklahoma
with the pact well with the big 12
essentially disintegrating because of
oklahoma and texas leaving if iowa state
could somehow pull off some sort of
cinderella run on behalf of the
remainder of the big 12 force their way
into a college football playoff and go
on a run i know that that is such
fantasy when you just named some of the
blue bloods right there as your top five
but that would just be incredible
certainly with you know matt campbell as
i mentioned the 41
members of the historic alliance pac-12
big ten in acc that of the 41 member
schools there about 90 would would ditch
their current coach for campbell if he
was available to them i would yeah yeah
they would they would and uh it would
make for a much easier trophy
presentation for bob bullsby at the uh
big 12 championship i know that
well it would be
it would definitely be something you
would sign for but the the fact that you
didn't even take that particular uh
piece of red meat that i threw out there
means that uh that ain't gonna happen in
your estimation
well i you know i got a montana too so i
met that i think that's exceptional uh
for them i just i don't know if they can
overcome oklahoma alex grinch was the
biggest piece the missing link i felt
like lincoln riley needed to bring in a
few years ago the defensive coordinator
came from ohio state he was formerly at
washington state really turned things
around there and produced uh a solid
defense in in mike leech's wake which is
really extremely difficult
he's improved every single year with
oklahoma they're going to turn the
football over and when that happens with
the potency of that offense you're not
going to be able to stay with this
oklahoma team because they just you
won't have enough possessions because
they are able to turn the football over
that some alex grinch has always been
really good at and getting his players
to do so uh it's going to be tough for
for a team to get past the sooner team
but if there's one team that can do it
rich it's iowa state i think they are
the they are the next team there texas i
think is a seven and five team under
stark and year one so no one's gonna be
really
happy about that by the way ryan leaf i
saw how you broke down the big 12 on
your twitter account
seven and five for texas seven and four
yeah
really you believe that yeah i do i just
think they are i mean
sam ellinger
you know was
he was the reason why they were able to
get to eight nine
wins every year and without him and
breaking in somebody new in a new system
with the new
no identity really i think it in texas
uh yeah i think that this could be a
seven and five team i mean if they
you know i've got no few arguments with
with with some longhorn homers around uh
them getting more than seven wins i
think i got a few steak dinners bet on
it this season but yeah i i got him at
7-5 all right before i let you go ryan a
little bit in the nfl because the
conversation
involving justin fields and whatever uh
might happen with trey lance and jimmy
garoppolo up in santa clara california
that's the annual conversation
of do you throw your top drafted
quarterback and the deep end of the pool
if you don't have to
obviously jacksonville and the jets
have to obviously back in your day the
chargers kind of had to right um and so
with you
but the concept of learning
on the side to see and watch and mature
and soak in
uh as opposed to just throwing them in
like uh justin herbert got thrown in
albeit the circumstances were different
what's your stance
on all of that
ryan leaf
i feel like the players that are coming
out of college are much better prepared
to handle what the nfl is throwing at
them specifically because of the
offenses that are being run and the
ability for head coaches and offensive
coordinators to shape
their game plans around what
quarterbacks do best back in my day even
as back as recently as jared goff in his
rookie year with jeff fisher jeff
jefferson just wasn't willing to bend
towards what jared goff was great at and
we saw the product on the football field
when sean mcvay came in he really
understood what made jared goff great
and they applied that uh and got
themselves to a super bowl and i think
coaches do that now if i'm on the team
out there i i'd want to follow in the
footsteps of what patrick holmes did
when you have a reliable veteran
quarterback who can get you to where you
need to get to
uh and not have to worry about someone
breaking somebody in
then you go about it that way it's i
think it's a perfect opportunity for san
francisco and trey lance to let him sit
behind a a capable quarterback who's
been to a super bowl jimmy garoppolo the
difference is
does
kyle shanahan believe that this is the
player that separates the san francisco
49ers from winning that super bowl two
years ago
from what jimmy garoppolo can do and not
overthrow the wide open receiver for the
touchdown that would win if he believes
that then trey lance is going to be in
the game from day one it just that's
just how it's going to be now we're
talking about chicago and justin fields
i don't know how good this chicago bears
team is
um and
i do think that justin fields is going
to have his
uh hiccups along the way but he's the
most dynamic player of the quarterbacks
i just feel like andy dalton's probably
the answer there early on
but i wouldn't but but matt maggie's
gotta gotta keep his job and the only
way for him to keep his job is to put
the best possible playoff player out
there to make plays regardless of what
that looks like and that has to be
justin field so i'd start him from day
one yeah i i i i would agree with you
on that ryan leaf and
the one thing i would say that
college football quarterbacks don't
appear to be prepared for in the nfl
because the college football world does
not prepare them for it
um while i do agree with you about the
offenses and the schemes coming in is
the is the the
mechanism to call the play like in the
pros they're not holding up photographs
of scott van pelt and you know like a a
flag of ireland and then a you know a
hammer you know and then and then having
four other guys do you know hand signals
in semaphore and that's the thing that
drives me a little bit nuts about
college football these days is everybody
gets lined up and it looks like they're
about to snap it but then they all stand
up and all of them look to the sideline
and then they all look back and then now
they know what play to be called is that
because college football coaches don't
think the kids have the ability or
they're just such control freaks that's
the way they want to do it like because
if i'm a college football coach first
kid that i can say i'm sending to the
nfl as a quarterback fully ready to call
a 12 word play call because he knows who
he's addressing it to i i'd get every
single five-star recruit at that
position in my estimation i i agree with
you i think that there's probably that
where in terms of optimization but i
also think in terms of college coaches
feel like this speeds things up and they
want to run as many plays as possible in
the nfl they want to run plenty of place
but they want to run
effective plays like when we like
college football practice now it doesn't
matter what the play does it could be a
complete bust of a play they want to get
it on film they're going to coach it up
in the film room they're not going to
coach it up out on the field necessary
they want to run as many plays as they
can so
yeah that's that's a big difference for
these guys when they make that job i'm
also
and i've been this way ever since i had
to deal with with mike holmgren calling
plays in seattle i asked him one time
why can't we just call this play like uh
boomerang instead of you know x out wise
you know wide
the
zebra
and banana you know why why can't we
just call this play you know right zebra
or something like that and so everybody
knows it
um and he looked at me like i was crazy
and i suppose i was but uh i just i
thought that would just be more more
convenient and easier for guys to do it
same with john gruden in tampa yeah it
doesn't make too much sense right
let everybody else learn what the hell
that means you just say the word zebra
you know what it means and everybody
knows what it means and let's go is it
yeah
because that's apparently one of the
things that justin fields has yet to be
able to do is that albert brewer told us
is to is to absorb the play call
and address each member in the huddle
you know and address each member in the
huddle for whatever that part of the
play call is assigned to
um
like andy dalton you know listen listen
to this rich so i i when i was with
coach holmgren and we have those
speakers in our in our ear
by the time he finished with the play
call in my ear i i i had a hard time
remembering what the damn formation was
that started the whole play
uh in particular and i'd walk into the
huddle i don't know if you remember the
the
nfl film stuff with chris sims when he'd
step into the huddle and john gruden was
calling the play exactly the same thing
john gruden would pull off a 15-word
play and by the time chris was ready to
call it he couldn't remember what the
formation was and would get yelled at on
on nfl films by everybody it was a
running joke with everybody brad johnson
and that crew yeah it was uh it it makes
for some comedy but you're exactly right
that is something and being under center
that's another big thing these kids are
never under center and you're going to
have to be in the nfl because it has to
be physical and you got to get a yard
sometime
not just sit back there in the gun and
hand it off five yards deep send my best
sir to paul burmeister have a great time
in the rose bowl calling hawaii ucla on
westwood one ryan leaf you take care i
appreciate it also i heard the jameis
winston stuff i'd like to blame my uh
entire nfl career on the fact that i
didn't get lasik yet very good
all right
thank you very much take care ryan all
right that's right
it's ryan leaf all right hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here